alexandre langlois merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france alors
pensez vous que la création de cette
nouvelle unité aidera vraiment les
policiers sur le terrain
malheureusement non c'est que monsieur
da manha vente même pas l'eau chaude il
avant que l'eau tiède comme mes
collègues syndicalistes d'autres
syndicats l'ont souligné
c'est déjà le rôle des crs s'est déjà
les missions des crs mais les crs
s'employer à te faire tout et n'importe
quoi aujourd'hui donc ils ne peuvent
plus remplir leur coeur de métier
la deuxième chose également là il va
faire une élite et est à lacérer suite
se dire qu'il va vider les 150
fonctionnaires l'acr et suite pourra
mettre 200 dans cette nouvelle unité
donc en fait il ne crée rien ay faire un
tour de passe passe est un joueur de
bonneteau il change les personnels de
place et va leur dire cette fois ci vous
allez faire votre métier pour lequel
vous êtes pas engagé mais c'est
complètement lunaire comme réaction nous
sommes dans la communication la
surcommunication pour finalement quelque
chose qui va pas mieux marché qu'avant
parce que c'est le rôle des crs qui donc
est détournée de l'ambition par ces
mêmes politiques et en plus il peut ya
voir même une application financière
pour nos collègues qui sont payés pour
leur genre de déplacement s'il a en plus
ils ne sont pas mobilisés sur certaines
missions dans d'autres départements ils
auront une perte de salaire donc c'est
contreproductif pour la protection des
citoyens et pour financièrement pour les
policiers alors manifestement ces unités
seront équipés avec de nouveaux
équipements dont des 4 4
pourquoi ne pas équiper celles déjà
existantes ben justement voilà on est
sûr de la communication si jamais on
équiper toutes les compagnies de crs
normalement ce serait bien mais donc là
c'est un aveu d'échec de monsieur
darmanin il dit je n'ai pas le budget
pour donner les moyens à la police
d'exercer ses missions
donc du coup plutôt que de dire que je
suis nulle et que je ne sais pas comment
faire je vais créer une unité d'élite en
dix ans elle l'âge l'équipe bien mais
voilà donc en fait c'est juste un aveu
d'échec de ce gouvernement dont la
priorité n'est pas la sécurité mais les
gadgets et la communication
alors il ya des syndicats qui parlent
d'un manque de concertation
comment gérald darmanin on est arrivés
la farce constat sudermann est dans sa
tour d'ivoire la concertation on a bien
pu voir que quel soit les syndicats qui
ne reçoit pas comme le nôtre les
syndicats représentatifs qui sont
squeezé parce que monsieur maquereau a
choisi unités gp ni uniquement comme un
interlocuteur par exemple pour le
beauvau de la sécurité ça pose des
complications donc c'est même pas un
manque de consultation c'est un
consultation n'ayant n'y a pas de
dialogue social au sein de la police
nationale
nous avons un monsieur darmana dans sa
tour d'ivoire et nous sommes sommés
d'appliquer les décisions prises par ses
conseillers technocratique
il ya des syndicats de crs qui parle
également d'une volonté de démanteler
justement les crs qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
bah c'est un risque éventuellement si
c'est le rêve de monsieur sarkozy à
l'époque qui voulaient démanteler les
compagnies de crs finalement les avis
des deux moitiés les gendarmes sont
moins mobilisés et à la moitié des
escadrons de gendarmerie qui avait été
supprimé aujourd'hui on est encore sur
quelque chose on se dit bah les crs
coûte cher oui coûte cher mais ils sont
utiles pour maintenir l'ordre ils sont
utilisés dans les bonnes conditions
d'ailleurs je rappelle que sur toutes
les manifestations de maintien de
l'ordre
grâce à leur professionnalisme s'est
passé unités là qui permette qui évite
les blés si justement elle évite les
baisser évite les dérapages donc
continuons de les former alors après si
c'est un jeu de bonneteau pour dire on
va créer csu pérennité pour fermer les
unités de crs oui il s'attaquera
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui se passe tout de
suite la crs suit donc dans le sud de
l'ile-de-france va fermer pour laisser
place à une nouvelle unité de super crs
donc on est juste sur un tour de passe
passe
alors cette unité devrait être déployé
en cas de troubles graves avec la
crainte d' escalade de violence quel
type d'événement selon vous seront
concernés par ces nouvelles équipes
alors n'en sais rien a vu que c'est le
chaos dans la france que rien n'est fait
pour gérer déjà la police au quotidien
pour maintenir la confiance avec la
population pour maintenir la sécurité
dans différents quartiers
c'est des communautés comme tchétchènes
à dijon qui font la loi sur les
manifestations les policiers n'ont pas
l'ordre d'interpeller les gens qui
viennent commettre des actes criminels
et délictuelles mais uniquement de
réprimer les manifestants qui viennent
derrière donc en fait déjà ça va on ne
sait pas sur quoi cela va être utilisée
parce que déjà la police à l'ats moyens
d'agir en tant que tel il faut qu'elle
soit juste commandes et de façon
cohérente et efficace et aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas ça nous n'avons pas ces
politiques et le prendre les bonnes
décisions
nous n'avons pas des directeurs qui sont
capables de s'opposer aux politiques qui
sont plus des courtisans et aujourd'hui
c'est le chaos complet
donc là on est dans de la communication
mais malheureusement sur le terrain ça
ne va rien changer il pourra les
déployer où ils veulent
c'est pas 200 personnes de plus qui vont
faire la différence il ya des unités de
crs déjà qu'ils sont là il ya des
policiers qui s'occupe d'eux dans les
quartiers il ya des policiers qui font
répondre à l'appel 17 donc chacun joue
son rôle et ses missions pour lesquelles
il est employé essayera déjà beaucoup
mieux alors on a le veau de la sécurité
on qui devrait pas tarder à commencer
puisque ça a été annoncé au mois de
décembre pour le mois de janvier
qu'est-ce que
vous en attendez de cette grande réunion
ça se termine vite parce que c'est une
mascarade on est en train de nous
préparer une pièce de théâtre une pièce
de théâtre déjà rien que pour le motif
comment il a été convoqué il a été
convoqué par monsieur macro embâcles
secrétaire général uniquement d'unités
gp qui adhérent à la république en
marche car que même le ministre de
l'intérieur et les autres partenaires
syndicaux n'ont pas été informés ils ont
découvert par voie de presse donc on est
dans du clientélisme et du copinage déjà
le fondement du bo de la série de pied
commence mal deuxième chose également
toutes les organisations syndicales qui
vont être reçus c'est celle qui ont fait
des manifestations sauvages illégales
qui ont marché sur place beauvau qui ont
fait d intimider et des juges qui ont
intimidé des élus de la république à
rennes les juges étaient à tour c'est
ces gens là qui vont être appelés à
passer aux bobos de la sécurité pendant
cela d'autres organisations syndicales
dans la nôtre
tous les délégués sont réprimés parce
qu'ils ont manqué de loyauté envers le
chef plutôt qu'envers le peuple
ils ont porté atteinte au crédit et
ronan de la police nationale parce
qu'ils ont dénoncé des
dysfonctionnements
plutôt que de les taire donc voilà donc
on a repris l'équipe des copains coquins
et bah finalement il va rien d'en sortir
donc que cette mascarade se termine le
plus vite possible pour que ça coûte le
moins d'argent possible aux
contribuables et si un jour monsieur
mâcon et son gouvernement voulait
réellement discuter mais il commencerait
par mettre le holà tous ces gens qui
sont des factieux et écouterait les gens
qui lancent des alertes depuis des
années alexandre langlois merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire général vigie
police merci à vous merci à vous